this indictment helps Trump
in the Republican primary I agree with
that I don't think that if there is
another indictment in Georgia
and potentially a Federal indictment
that it will be good for Trump at all
because it really will hinder his
ability to run his campaign and secondly
I don't understand how this indictment
gets Trump a single new vote in a
general election this indictment and
potentially future indictments make
Trump seem even more chaotic than we've
already known him to be and the chaos
that surrounds him and so while this may
help Trump secure the Republican
nomination if it doesn't end up
interfering if the indictments keep
coming I think this is bad for Trump in
a general election